Shin of Member of Parliament for the
Brentford and eyes with constituency 8th
of June 2017
declaration a result of poll I the
undersigned being the returning officer
at the election held on Thursday the 8th
of June 2017 do hereby give notice that
the number of votes cast for each
candidate as the election is as follows
Joseph Gerald orc known as Joe bought
Liberal Democrats 3083 Ruth Margaret to
Cadbury Labour Party thirty-five
thousand thirty five thousand three
hundred and sixty four Mary McLeod
Conservative Party twenty three thousand
one hundred and eighty two the number of
ballot papers rejected was as follows
want of official mark zero voting for
more than one candidate 22 writing or
mark by which the vote could be
identified zero unmarked or void for
uncertainty 134 the total number of
ballot papers rejected 156 total votes
60 1785 and I hereby declare that roof
Cadbury has been duly elected for the
friend
when Isaac parliamentary constituency I
now invite the winning candidate to make
a speech madam mayor I first of all like
to thank Mary and Cassie and all the
people who worked so hard on this
election for you to make sure that it
won't run smoothly and efficiently both
in the polling stations and here tonight
at the count thank you to all of your
teams I'd like to thank the many other
people who made today possible the
schools the community centers and the
other the other places where the elect
the polling stations took place I'd like
to thank hands most police who supported
the oversight of today's election and
I'd also like to while I'm here thank
them for their part in supporting London
and Londoners after last Saturday
night's atrocity at London Bridge the
result tonight was due to a number of
factors and will be all be spending the
next days and weeks working all of that
out but I'd like to particularly that
like to thank my amazing Labor team
first of all my organizer technically a
trainee organizer Jack Jack prize
Jack that wasn't bad for a first attempt
also he was supported by James Wendell
Hurst and Dave Clark but also the
hundreds of volunteers we had over
recent weeks and today from Brentford
and izalith but from further afield
people came from as far afield as Dublin
and Essex today and all parts in between
also my mum Jill who's come over from
Birmingham Sam who came back from uni
and Nottingham all came from a long way
to come and help I'd also like to thank
my husband Nick for all his support in
there in recent weeks I'd really also be
part of my result was due to the
responses we've been able to give to the
22,000 plus requests for support and
help in the last two years and that
would not have been possible without my
amazing Westminster team Joe Amy
Karissa Charlotte and plan'n thank you
so much you have worked above and beyond
long hours dedicated your work is really
appreciated not just by me but to those
you've managed to help I'd like to thank
Mary and Joe for a fair campaign I'd
also like to thank Diana and the Green
Party for taking the courageous decision
not to stand in this election but most
importantly I'd like to make the people
a bread for Don izalith who voted
against school cuts who voted against
cuts to the NHS and Care Services who
voted against police cuts who vent voted
against the hard brexit who voted
against so many of the policies of the
Conservative government and who voted
for hope for a change I'm honoured to
have been elected again as MP for rent
for the knives with constituency I
commit to serve you
again as hard as I can until the next
general election thank you very much
[Applause]